i think what we need in washington is
people who understand
how the elites plunder this country and
then blame us for it in the process
we need people in washington dc who
knows how the system
works who knows how to reform that
system and who can make this country
better
and that's why i'm running to be your
next u.s senator for the state of ohio
jay vance became famous several years
ago he's a lawyer and a businessman but
he wrote one of the best-selling books
in the country was a kind of memoir he
spent a lot of time
on this show and as you just saw he
announced hours ago that he is running
for a u.s
senate seat from the state of ohio he's
entering the republican primary along
with several other candidates to replace
the retiring senator rob portman
j.d vance joins us for his first
interview since that announcement
congratulations jd this is
what why are you doing this you've had
this successful life
and now you're moving into the tough
very tough business of politics why
well because i care about this country
and i care about this state tucker if
you think about the entire
trajectory of american life over the
last 30 or 40 years
you have elites in the ruling class that
have plundered this country that have
made it harder for middle-class
americans to live a normal life
and when those americans dare to
complain about the conditions of their
own country if they dare to complain
about the southern border
or about jobs getting shipped overseas
what do they get called they get called
racists they get called bigots
xenophobes or idiots they need somebody
who's willing to speak for them who's
willing to fight
for them and i just want normal
americans to know
they still have a voice in this country
they love this country but they should
be able to criticize it when it's not
working for them and right now it's just
not
i love that i i this is not false
flattery i don't think i've ever met
anybody who understands both
worlds as well as you do you you grew up
there in a very working-class
environment then you wound up at yale
law school in a completely different
world and you you really i think
understand what's gone wrong with the
country
but you're an intellectual and a writer
are you ready for
the nastiness politics it's a totally
different world
you know i'm ready for the nastiness of
politics tucker because i think it's
worth going
through that nastiness to actually do
something worthwhile i have two boys
i love those kids i want them to live in
the same great country that i lived in
and if we don't do something if we don't
fight back against what's going on in
our country
they're going to lose it they're going
to grow up in a country that's much
poorer that's much
dirtier that's much uglier and where
they can't even speak their mind as
citizens so yeah
i'm going to get attacked by it i've
already been attacked by it even since
the announcement
cnn has gone after me the establishment
republicans have gone after me
uh the the leadership of course of the
other campaigns have gone after me even
tim ryan the democrat has gone after me
it's time to fight back though if you're
not willing to wade through a little
crap to save this country
then you're not willing to stand up on
the big stage and i am yeah
because they know you're you're an
actual threat because you you really do
have their number
for real how have national republicans
i know that at times i mean you're a
republican you're running as a
republican at times you've been
disappointed by the national party
how have they responded
well i think so far a lot of them are
frustrated and they're a little upset
with me because i actually say what's
true which is that many of these people
don't care about their own voters they
think they're either bigoted or they
think they're stupid they don't
understand their job in this country
is to protect their own voters to serve
their best interests so a lot of
establishment republicans just like a
lot of the mainstream press a lot of the
corporate media
they're against me they're against me
and they're gonna be against me and
that's fine
you're they're gonna they're gonna hit
you pretty hard do you i mean you expect
that
uh they're gonna hit me very hard
they're gonna come after my family
they're gonna come after me personally
but you know what
uh i i think it's worth it right tucker
this is a country that i know you love
i love and it's worth it to wade through
this stuff i think i can take a punch in
the jaw as you know
i come from pretty rough circumstances i
did not come from an easy life
and i think that prepared me to actually
take on the challenge
of attacking the people who are trying
to destroy this country i'm excited to
do it
yeah well i probably shouldn't say so
i'm really glad you're doing it jd vance
i
admire you and i wish you luck very much
thank you for doing this congratulations
thanks to
thanks so much tucker please go to
jdvance.com to sign up and find out how
to help us
thanks tucker see ya well we spent an
entire
hour one of the reasons not embarrassed
to say admire jd vance is because we
spent over an hour talking to him about
his life
really an interesting conversation it's
on tucker carlson today at fox nation
if you want to watch hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else